auch ich habe heute ein thema
mitgebracht aber dass ich einfach
nachdenklich bin ich weiß gar nicht ob
es mich freut oder ja ich möchte es
einfach mal teil und zwar bin ich der
festen überzeugung dass wir aufhören
sollen die maske zu tragen nicht nur
weil ich finde dass bei den aktuellen
umfragen und genesenen raten ist nicht
mehr nötig ist sondern vor allem auch
der umwelt zuliebe denn alle sprechen
immer darüber dass der aufwand sein
fleisch zu essen wir sollen nicht mehr
auto fahren aber auch dass maske tragen
es sich gut für unsere umwelt ein
beispiel die maske wenn man mit einem vw
diese ein halber kilometer fährt hat man
genauso viel co2 ausgestoßen wie immer
man die maske einmal trägt und da wir
alle fast nur noch einen weg masken
tragen also die op masken und die ffw
zwei masken ist also pro masken gebrauch
ein halber kilometer mit einem vw diesel
in beiden fällen sind das 50 gramm dazu
kommen noch das recycling problem ich
meine das jetzt hier natürlich schon mit
einem augenzwinkern aber ich bin dafür
weg mit der maske der umwelt zuliebe
nicht mehr ich muss ich muss ich fragen
was ist das ist das manipulationsversuch
willst du die klimaaktivisten und die
grünen irgendwie hinter sich bringen
damit sie auch zu erbitterten masken
gegnern werden zum glück haben wir heute
einen grünen da da kann man ihn auch
direkt fragen würde denn dieses umwelt
dieses klimaschutz argument zählen um
die leute von der maya gegen die masten
pflicht mal aufzubringen herr ball macht
also da würde ich wahrscheinlich mit
karl marx sagen man möge doch die haupt
und die neben widersprüche sauber
trennen und ich halte das für neben
widerspruch und was halten sie von der
maske beziehungsweise von der masten
pflicht ganz im allgemeinen kommt auf
den ort an und auf den impfstatus gibt
situationen da finde ich masken sehr
angemessen wenn ich jetzt mal einen voll
nahverkehrszug denkt wo alle irgendwie
packt sind im schulbus soll ich sagen
viertelstunde die maske tragen scheint
mir sehr sinnvoll wenn man mir das
gleiche vorschlägt in den biergarten sag
ich leuchtet mir nicht ein und wie
halten sie es mit schulen da wird das
thema ja am heißesten diskutiert da hat
ja baden württemberg gibt es gerade
diese woche entschieden dass es in
schulen nicht mehr vorgeschrieben ist
finde ich interessant vor allem weil ja
nur eins richtig sein könnten also
entweder ist es jetzt wichtiger dass die
kinder sich sehen und dabei auch
spracherwerb und mimik und alles lernen
darum jetzt
und das ist dann wichtiger als der
korona schutz oder vor einem halben jahr
als man ja noch viel weiter gegangen ist
und die schulen zu gemacht hat weiß ja
noch schlimmer ist als keine maske zu
tragen ist irgendwas falsch gemacht
worden da muss man sich irgendwie dann
wahrscheinlich rückblicken mal
verständigen wo die risiken richtig und
wo sie falsch wahrgenommen worden sind
ich glaube jetzt ist es richtig ich
würde den schulen jetzt nicht mehr
jahrelang machst mir vorschreiben so ich
finde die müssen sich sehen können
entsprechen ich würde es noch für
überspitzt sagen masken sollten sofort
weg in den schulen also ich finde vor
allem auch bei in grundschulen auch bei
kleineren kindern muss man ja auch sagen
wenn die sich anstecken sind sie auch
meistens asymptomatisch das ist das
thema für kinder war immer klar es ist
nicht besonders gefährlich sich mit
corona zu infizieren sondern es ist eine
genetische erkrankung und so etwa ab 50
steigt das risiko an für ein kind ist
corona wie die teilnahme am
straßenverkehr kommt auch mal ein unfall
vor ist aber nicht wirklich so
gefährlich dass man deswegen nicht mehr
auf die straße geht während für den
80-jährigen ist corona halt wie die
teilen aber russisch roulette wo jede
sechste kugel tödlich ist und deswegen
muss man da unterschiedlich reagiert zum
einen punkt darin den klang interessant
fand masken unbeschadet ihrer
hygienischen nutzanwendung sind
zunehmend auch in unseren städten ein
ästhetisches problem dass man sich schon
mal sagen wie häufig sich so darauf dass
auf der straße nicht
im gesicht verhindern dann vielleicht
sogar eines ethischen probleme aber auf
der straße werden sie oft wirklich stand
wie ausgelegter sondermüll wirkt das
also man läuft durch unterführungen und
es ist kein mensch da aber es liegen 20
30 hässliche zerfetzte schmutzig
gewordenen masken am velo an gestattet
gut ist kann ich doch wieder reinigen
unsere allseits geliebten berlin
sprechen aber ich war jetzt woche auch
in einem anderen bundesland und die
entsorgung von masken schatten überhaupt
nicht durchdacht zu sagen ich habe den
eindruck es fühlt sich auch kaum jemand
dafür zuständig die selber richtig zu
entsorgen oder b dass sie von der
stadtreinigung eingesammelt werden es
ist einfach ästhetische vermüllung der
stadt wenigstens einer der mir auch mit
der umwelt
siehst du das masken thema ach sie haben
wird als diese ganzen eröffnung der
diskussion jetzt von deiner seite
alexander kissler da noch beigesprungen
ist muss ich einfach sagen
offensichtlich habe diese grüne religion
mittel jetzt auch auf diesem tisch
besitz von den hirnen ergriffen also ich
könnte mit ihrer argumente vorstellen
die klima hast aber das mit der umwelt
es ist also eines der letzten mich ich
muss auch ich war jetzt nie im heiligen
krieg gegen die maske gibt es solche die
den heiligen krieg geführt haben ich bin
einfach nicht zum beispiel meine
argumente haben im himmel wie man eine
spirale geriet aber die ich finde die
maske ist für mich einfach die
mautpflicht finde ich irritierend weil
in der schweiz zum beispiel haben sie am
anfang als die regierung viel zu wenig
masken hatte hatten sie gesagt die
masken bringen nichts dabei hatten wir
einfach keine das macht stand ganz kann
und jetzt aber wo man langsam vielleicht
auch andere mittel hat sich zu schützen
kann man gar nicht genug masken tragen
und in der schule da habe ich ihn
wahnsinnig
aufwühlenden artico kürzlich gelesen im
wall street journal und hat ein
mediziner der johns hopkins universität
also krankheits katalog aufgezeichnet
was kinder die diese maske tragen müssen
in den schulen sie haben die mimik
angesprochen nicht das ist auch etwas
wichtig ist aber auch erkrankungen bis
hin zur gesichts deformierungen ist weiß
ich nicht wie das möglich ist aber dass
wurde von einem professor der
johns-hopkins-universität
dargelegt also die maske ist kann man
aus anderen dritten ablegen letzter
punkt auch nochmal aus der schweiz da
hat eine politikerin einmal während der
pandemie gesagt die maske sei ein
pädagogisches symbol bei uns daran wie
schlimm diese pandemie sei also die
maske ist auch ein symptom des
erziehungs staats und deshalb würde ich
sagen jedes team ausgetragen ab die
pflicht freiwillig freiwillig herr
palmer sie würden doch hervorragend in
die schweiz passen oder mit diesem
freiheits bild gerade was corona angeht
weniger volks erziehung und mehr
eigenverantwortung das passt doch ganz
gut haben sie völlig recht aber die
würden mich trotzdem nicht reinlassen
die sind da sehr aus wählerisch nein
also da muss ich ihnen sorgen
wir haben mittlerweile etwas
organisieren
nach 25 deutsche und ich bin ja auch
noch schweizer dann eine pause wir
brauchen auch noch ein paar
schlaue ich schätze dass jetzt in der
schweiz vieles und ich finde auch
politisch gibt es dort ein angebot ist
bei uns fehlt die grünliberale partei
also nicht dass die parteien spaltung
gut finde aber ich habe große sympathien
für die grünliberale partei die bei uns
ja nur sozusagen als geduldete
minderheit in der partei der grünen
existiert und möglicherweise jetzt mit
dem koalitionspartner fdp sogar ein paar
sachen hinkriegen kann aber eigentlich
fehlt es in deutschland grün und liberal
zu sein gibt es kein echtes angebot den
wir da kriegst du sozusagen das liberale
angebote fdp im wesentlichen ohne
ökologie das war ein bisschen
vorgeschoben verfahren zeige aber
eigentlich kein interesse an ökologie
oder du kriegst halt ist was wir nennen
sie das klima religion wie auch immer da
wo halt dann ist das moralisieren und
die leute irgendwie da in was rein
zwingend so dominierten beides gefällt
mir eigentlich nicht gerne grünliberale
partei aber wenn cannabis legalisiert
wird das wird auch am grünliberalen
wurde
das ist mir egal weil ich so nie
ausprobiert habe das sollen andere
beurteilen aber sie können die partei
selbst gründen weil sie ja
ein parteiausschlussverfahren aber weiß
ich nicht kann ich gleichzeitig in der
schweiz aus gründen auswandern
schweizer exil vielleicht noch was ist
links und parteigründungen es
gut wenn sie zb auch in einer grünen
partei
unterschiedliche meinungen und
unterschiedliche richtungen haben ich
bin nicht so sicher ob eine abspaltung
manchmal mit den grünliberalen
das ist vielleicht das grünliberaler
sich gut aber die grünen haben sich
dadurch eine stärken eine ideologisch
gefärbt und solange es leute wie sie in
der grünen partei sind haben sie eine
lebhafte diskussion und
auseinandersetzung also ich würde doch
etwas abraten gleich die die quasi
wissen an dem die phasen trennung 1 2
naja auch nicht wehre ich mich dagegen
dass dem ich groß über zellteilung
also dieses ausschlussverfahren
lange hin dieses verfahren wurde am
achten mal beschlossen und seither ist
nichts passiert gar nichts aber nichts
also das ist das
parteiausschlussverfahren das eröffnet
wurde weil sie auf facebook dass
entwickler haben es wurde nicht daran
sich gerade der witz also es gibt einen
parteitagsbeschluss davor stellen soll
es eröffnet und er hat ist ein halbes
jahr nichts getan vielleicht weil frau
berbalk zufälligerweise in einer in
einem video selbst das n wort gesagt hat
und das würde sie vielleicht in die
bredouille bringen ich kann ihnen dann
keine gründe nennen
sturmmaske zurückgehen wir sind jetzt
aufgerufen das
ist nicht dies wird in der partei
nein ich glaube auch nicht mehr mit mach
ich kann nicht mehr mithalten ich
verstehe das nicht
sie haben völlig recht ich bleibe dabei
weil ich finde dass die grünen diesen
widerspruch den erhalt zum ausdruck
bringen dass die dinge brauchen wir
nicht ab zu das nennt man doch sie haben
markt zieht das ist durch dialektik
nicht direkt asse sind diese these auf
der reise plant